una visita a la línea de frente el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
llegó a una de las zonas más peligrosas
en la región de donbass las violaciones
del cese al fuego se han cobrado las
vidas de cada vez más soldados
ucranianos desde que empezó el año
mataron 26 hombres el ejército hace todo
lo posible para defender nuestro país y
mantener el cese al fuego de nuevo news
pero cuando atacan a nuestros soldados y
hay bajas está claro que el ejército
respondía
si los misiles no armé
rusia ya ha asegurado que bajo ciertas
circunstancias no dudaría en responder
con contundencia ambas partes se culpan
mutuamente por la intensificación del
conflicto en donbass el miedo de llegar
a la violencia a gran escala en la
región empeoró con escenas así tropas
rusas acumulándose a lo largo de la
frontera frente a los ruegos de alemania
de retirarlas el presidente putin
aseguró que estaban ahí para desescalar
tensiones causadas por kiev
el martes selenski pidió a la otan a
acelerar la entrada de ucrania en la
alianza militar ya que cree que es la
única manera de resolver el conflicto
provocado por la anexión rusa de crimea
en 2014
un alto al fuego se acordó durante el
siguiente año fruto de los acuerdos de
links negociados con francia y alemania
pero en donbass los disparos y los
enfrentamientos esporádicos nunca
cesaron más de 13.000 personas han
muerto en los enfrentamientos entre los
separatistas pro rusos y el ejército
ucraniano